beyond the starkness of all this
a town destroyed it is the silence which
hits you
there is nothing left here greenville
california
population 1000 swept away in the
largest single forest fire
this state has ever seen it's only when
you see it up close that you get a real
sense of the level of destruction here
this is main street and
in almost every corner this town has
been completely destroyed
by the fire businesses livelihoods
homes all of them all gone
the people whose town this was were
almost all evacuated
but most have lost everything the local
restaurant is only recognizable
by the tables and chairs still set the
town's businesses
are marked by their metal filing
cabinets
with all this around you look for hope
and around the corner by some miracle
there was some one house survived not a
scratch
it belongs to sherry and terry wurt oh
my gosh
terry you gotta come oh
oh it looks perfect the residents are
not allowed back yet
and honestly most won't want to see the
destruction
but it is a boost certainly for these
two it's amazing how it's completely
unscathed and you could see your um
your wind vane over there is uh is still
going around
the wing catcher oh fantastic
it's an hour down to the town where the
evacuees now wait
terry and sherry among them our home is
still there and
we're one of the very few lucky people
and my heart just goes out to her
community
but they say these fires are avoidable
if the forests had been better managed
as the weather becomes more extreme now
it's a annual thing it ruins every
summer it takes people's homes away it's
taken people's lives
so it's a combination of of bad forest
management
and and that the climate is changing and
then
yeah exactly i mean it's a tinderbox we
have
we're not getting near amount of the
rain precipitation that we used to get
nor the snowpack even up high this is
happening year on year
is it the case that they're not going to
you're not going to be able to live
there in the future
it's just not sustainable no i don't
believe that
i believe the viability of communities
like this does feel ever more precarious
and dependent on our relationship with
the environment
local and global mark stone sky news
in california